The next question relates to a person
that is swallowing his or her own saliva
during the fast. Is this a permitted
act? As far as swallowing the salava is
concerned, it is a normal act. It's a
natural act. And today's science tells
us that there are several liters of
saliva being secreted by the salivary
gland every day. And it is normal. It's
natural that the saliva a human being
gulps it down. He swallows it. And this
can't be avoided. And Allah says in the
Quran in surah bakar chapter number two
verse number 185 when it tells you that
you should fast for the full month of
Ramadan and those who are ill on a
journey they can make up the period
later on. Then it says Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala wants to make it easy for you
and does not want to put you in a
difficulty. Allah says in surah chapter
number
22 verse number 78 Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala does not want to give you
hardship in your dean in your religion.
So but naturally since following saliva
is a normal act and I know that some
people keep on frequently spitting out
and I have some of my friends they do
that thinking it's haram to swallow and
they keep on spitting and imagine if you
have to do it the full day you cannot
even offer your salah properly because
when you offer salah takes a few minute
and in few minutes also saliva gets
gathered so will you be concentrating on
spitting the saliva out or Allah
subhanaa tala if the Quran you'll have
to keep on spitting outside always and I
know some people always
maybe a container always spitting out
not knowing the ruling. So if a person
follows the saliva normal saliva which
comes in the mouth it cannot be avoided
at all. Same way a person when he
breathes the dust which which a person
goes to a city which is polluted and
there's dust particles and you breathe
that and some of it goes in your lungs
or it goes so it's all this is
permissible because this is a normal
dated react and these do not violate
your fast at